my grip loosened on the bar and I just
went sailing through the air probably
went about 20 feet and the only thing
that stopped me was the wall of the
trampoline in my head I'm like oh my
gosh what just happened I have no idea
where I'm at am I gonna die am I gonna
land in my head like what's gonna happen
hi I'm Julian and today I'm gonna tell
you my gymnastics horror story when I
was in my early teens I was a
competitive gymnast I was on a team in
New Jersey when we would train we would
train for 3 hours a day every day of the
week so I was one of seven people on the
team and one day when we were training
we were all stationed at different event
spaces and my coach was kind of making
the rounds for each teammate and you
know giving some like one-on-one kind of
attention to each event the station that
I was at was the high bar for anyone who
doesn't know the high bar is a single
bar that is I guess about 12 feet in the
air and you just kind of do a bunch of
spins and stuff on it along the way so
as I was waiting for my coach to come
work with me I was just warming up with
a couple swings and a few giants which
are a full rotation around the bar as I
was doing this I was probably in like my
third go around the bar and I felt a rip
in my hand so what a rip is for anyone
who has been on the high bar or the
parallel bars or anything like that
probably knows a rip is when the callus
is ripped completely off your hand and
it leaves you with this giant gaping
wound yeah so you're just kind of like
skinless in a part of your hand it's
caused by the friction on the bar if you
don't use enough chalk or if you you
know we usually use a particular kind of
grip but it didn't do its job that day I
guess and so I got this massive rip on
my hand which is incredibly painful but
the worst part about it was I was I
think at the height of my swing at that
point and it was a little shocking so
like I my grip loosened on the bar and I
just went sailing through the air
probably went about 20 feet and the only
thing that stopped me was the wall of
the trampoline because we have
above-ground trampolines and they were
position
right behind the high bar so I smashed
right into the wall and then when I fell
to the ground it was of course
face-first and into a stool I guess one
of the coaches who was working with
someone else left the stool by the
trampoline not expecting anyone was
gonna go sailing through the air into it
you know I've got pinpoint accuracy so I
went face-first into this stool which
also was incredibly painful to make
matters worse all of this unfolded the
way our gym was set up was there was a
viewing window in the like waiting room
lobby where other gymnasts or parents of
gymnasts or yeah you know athletic
Scouts or anything it could be in this
room and watch people on the floor or in
on the bars whatever doing their thing
so this was a packed house and everyone
just watched me slam into a hole and
plant face-first onto the ground and a
coach comes running out and you know oh
my god are you okay are you okay like I
think I broke my neck or something and
you know I of course I said oh nothing
hurt but my pride but in reality I was
like I was in so much pain because that
was that was really a bad way to go
after that I kind of like took it took
it easy for the rest of the day but
luckily you're when you're that age I
guess you can you can bounce back and
recover quickly so I was a peck on the
bar in no time but it was a cautious
re-entry into the event for sure hi my
name is Jack and I'm gonna tell you my
gymnastics horror story so I think I was
about 14 going on 15 and I was in
Michigan at the time and I just moved
gymnastics gym so I was comfortable
doing gymnastics for about like three
years at this one gym that I grew up in
it was my like home gym and I decide if
I want to be good I had to move to
another gym my first week in this gym it
always I was like hey it's gonna be
great I was nervous everything and then
this event happened the very first week
as nobody knew who I was and all these
new people were around me I was already
nervous so the event was the rings and
the rings is where I can do the Iron
Cross and I like those strength moves
before the dismount at the end of my
routine you go up into a handstand and
you swing through the bottom and
something crazy happened at the bottom
of the swing so I was in a handstand and
I swung towards the bottom
the ring snapped in half and I flew like
a rag doll onto the ground so in my head
I'm like oh my gosh what just happened I
have no idea where I'm at am I gonna die
am I gonna land on my head like what's
gonna happen all of a sudden I like just
look up because thank God I was over one
of those pits where it's like all foamy
those things are gonna like save your
life I'm telling you if I was on the
actual mat I think I probably would have
like gotten hurt somehow but those foam
cubes are gonna save your life and they
saved mine and I look up and all of a
sudden everybody's in the gym looking at
me I have like a thousand eyes on me I
have no idea who these people are and
I'm brand-new they're like oh my god the
new kid just broke the Rings I look
around and I'm like I don't even know
what happened yet and then all of a
sudden some little kid points up at the
Rings and I look up and one of the Rings
is completely ripped in half and these
are made of like wood so they're not
supposed to break and I've never broken
any piece of equipment in my life but
this was the very first time and I was
like oh my gosh I literally just broke
the ring and to me I'm like oh my gosh
am I like that heavy that fat like
that's kind of crazy all of a sudden you
look over to the left and there's this
big piece of ring shattered in half and
I'm like oh my gosh but then it was also
kind of cool because I got to take it
home as well so I have a photo with like
my grips that I wear and the ring
snapped in half for the first week and a
half it was kind of like people weren't
like making fun of me but they were like
giving me the look I would say like they
were like judging me I was like oh this
person thinks I'm gonna break them like
the next equipment but after that I
think it actually helped with me making
more friends though for some reason
because then we had something to talk
about and like oh you're the kid that
broke the ring and I'm like yep that's
me like breaks the equipment I think was
like an old pair of rings though which
was not my fault hopefully but yeah even
like the people that make the Rings
they're not supposed to break so I guess
it was the right angle trajectory force
everything and of course it happened to
me but it was the scariest thing I've
ever had in my gymnastics career and you
never think like the equipment's gonna
break on you especially when you're in a
new gym - I was like wow they think I'm
gonna break all the equipment and so for
the next week I was worried about
breaking all the other events everybody
judging me all that kind of stuff but my
head was going crazy it was wild and
I've never had an experience like that
I'm having like PTSD like thinking about
it's kind of crazy but I'm praying that
never happens to me again it was
definitely a cool moment and a scary
moment at the same time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]